with the Tory conference now underway
the sky news petition to Parliament for
an independent commission to organize TV
debates and general elections has
reached 10,000 signatures in less than
two weeks that means the government now
has to respond to it people should keep
signing because we want to push on to a
hundred thousand which would mean a
parliamentary debate but of course don't
forget it is in the gift of the
Conservative Party at any point to say
they back to setting up a commission and
it would happen following Sky News
successfully lobbying for TV debates in
the 2010 election campaign three
head-to-head clashes between Gordon
Brown David Cameron and Nick Clegg were
held but since then broadcasters and
politicians have failed to agree on
terms and there were no head-to-head
debates between the leaders of the main
parties in the 2015 or 2017 general
election campaigns under our proposals
in which we call for head-to-head
debates between the leaders of the main
political parties a leadest debate
commission would set the format and
rules of the debates handle moderation
outlined the criteria for political
party participation ensure the
objectivity of audiences and steer
negotiations between broadcasters and
parties at the labor conference last
week senior opposition figures also
backed the Sky News campaign in the last
general election I attended the
cambridge debate I was there at those
debates the Prime Minister chose not to
turn up I think that was a terrible
shame Liberal Democrats Scottish
National Party and the Green Party are
all backing the Commission proposal but
Theresa May has yet to be won over
during her visit to the United Nations
last week she said the next general
election was not until 2022 and there
was plenty of time to think about those
issues at the time Sky News is arguing
that debate negotiations should take
place if
for an election campaign gets underway
John Craig Sky News I would want to
think